merci de vous être rendu disponible pour
venir ce matin devant la commission des
lois nous sommes heureux bien évidemment
de vous accueillir et si on pourrait
fermer la porte parce que les gens sont
bavards dans les couloirs et ça fait des
bruits
afin d'évoquer avec vous le rapport du
comité des états généraux de la justice
que vous avez remis au président de la
république au mois de juillet dernier
il est je le crois mais c'est un peu
délicat pour moi de le dire puisque j'ai
un peu participé modestement le fruit
d'un travail approfondi
qui a été menée entre le mois d'octobre
2021 et le mois d'avril 2022 il y a un
an d'ailleurs ce comité était à peu près
peut-être même à date annoncée
officiellement et sa composition
officiellement
il faut rappeler d'ailleurs que ce
ces états généraux ont été certes à
l'initiative du présent la république
mais
surtout après une intervention assez
forte je crois de même la première
présidente madame à reims et monsieur
mollins également auprès de du président
venant
expliquer la situation critique dans
laquelle se trouvait notre justice plus
de 7000 magistrats ont ensuite signé une
tribune dans la presse en réaction aux
suicides dramatique de l'une de leurs
collègues dénonçant
leurs conditions de travail et parfois
même la perte du sens de leur métier ce
qui était évidemment sans précédent
le malaise de notre justice est une
réalité incontestable
la perte de confiance des citoyens dans
son action mais aussi comme l'a montré
la chorale de la justice que nous avions
organisé au sénat il y a quasiment un an
jour pour jour à une semaine près
c'est réalité le sénat l'a mise en
lumière depuis plusieurs années en
faisant d'ailleurs des propositions qui
n'ont pas toujours reçu un avis
favorable de la chancellerie
ceci très trois principaux rapport que
la commission des lois a produit sur les
dates récente en 2010 est d'abord cinq
ans pour sauver la justice rapport assez
complet de la commission à l'époque
présidé par notre collègue philippe bas
en 2019 la justice prud'homale au milieu
du guet qui a été mené en commun avec la
commission des affaires sociales
montagne et même canayer ici présentes
en a été le rapporteur
et puis en 2021 le droit des entreprises
en difficulté à l'épreuve de la crise
dont nos collègues françois bonhomme et
monsieur thani mohamed soly furent
également les rapporteurs d'autres
travaux sont menés régulièrement bien
évidemment et en particulier en période
budgétaire après les avis qui sont
donnés par nora porter sur les
différentes thématiques liées à la
justice en clair si je puis me permettre
cette expression
la commission des lois et le sénat
depuis longtemps avait un quand même
signaler de grandes difficultés voire
mais est préconisé un certain nombre de
solutions il est donc très heureux de
retrouver de nombreux points de
convergence parmi les constats et
propositions qui ont été faites par les
états généraux
l'étape nouvelle est maintenant de sa
tâche et la mise en oeuvre de ces
propositions qu'il s'agisse des moyens
de l'organisation et du fonctionnement
de la justice ou des réformes
législatives le sénat bien évidemment il
veillera et nous tout particulièrement
il informe également il apporte
également que le ministère accepte de
changer de méthode en réformant la
justice de manière systémique au service
du justiciable et d'un meilleur
fonctionnement en évaluant en amont les
conditions pratiques nécessaires à la
réussite de ces réformes et sortent
d'une approche purement normative à cet
égard il nous faudrait modifier les
textes que lorsque cela est strictement
nécessaire
les jeux addictions sont épuisés par les
modifications incessantes des règles et
cela vaut tant pour la loi que pour les
textes réglementaires
nous avons pu le constater lors des
différents stages en jeu élections qui
ont été faits au sein des tribunaux
judiciaires de paris de lyon de bordeaux
2 lille de rouen et de marseille dans la
période du mois de septembre 2021 a au
mois de juin
2022 à peu près 13
13 collègues de la commission des lois
sont allés passer deux jours dans les
juridictions pour appréhender les
situations et nous continuerons de le
faire cette année dans des juridictions
sans doute de taille plus modeste
monsieur le président sauvez
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
comité je vais dans quelques instants
vous laisser la parole pour que vous
puissiez présenter les constats et
recommandations
j'ai cru comprendre dans tous les cas
c'est ce que l'on m'a dit que vous étiez
organisée je ne suis pas surpris de cela
en revanche entre vous de telle sorte
que même la présidente présidente
débutera à l'intervention j'évite de
monsieur le procureur général puis de
monsieur le président gavaudan et enfin
de monsieur sauver
à l'issue il y aura un jeu de questions
réponses comme ils disent âge mais je
rappelle que nous devons terminer notre
réunion un peu avant 11 heures il est 9h
on devrait pouvoir y arriver sans trop
de difficulté
bien je vous remercie de votre attention
je vais vous donner maintenant la parole
même la première présidente afin que
vous puissiez vous exprimer
merci monsieur le président comme vous
l'avait indiqué il y a eu beaucoup de
rapports 1 depuis plus de 20 ans
concernant le fonctionnement de la
justice avec un rapport très remarqués
celui de la commission des lois du sénat
en 2017 j'allais dire malheureusement
qui n'a pas été suivie de beaucoup
d'effet mais le constat était déjà
sévère
l'institution judiciaire est l'une de
celles qui s'est le plus réformé depuis
une trentaine d'années mais le constat
de l'ensemble des professionnels de
justice c'est que la justice est en très
grande difficulté comme vous l'avez
indiqué monsieur le président en juin
2021 mandaté par le conseil supérieur de
la magistrature en raison d' attaques
incessantes contre la justice le
procureur général françois molins c'est
moi même avons rencontré le président de
la république lui avons présenté l'état
de la justice et il a décidé de lancer
des états généraux qu'il a
officiellement lancé le 18 octobre 2000
21 il ya eu un partage des tâches entre
le ministère de la justice les
juridictions les avocats il comité des
états généraux en ce sens que le
ministère de la justice a lancé une
vaste consultation citoyenne auprès des
citoyens des professionnels il ya eu 50
mille contribution parallèlement il y a
eu des ateliers citoyens auxquels ont
participé les citoyens qui ont fait un
certain nombre de propositions il ya eu
des ateliers entre les citoyens et des
professionnels de justice
parallèlement il ya eu sept groupes de
travail
essentiellement composé de
professionnels de la justice qui en
trois mois ont proposé un certain nombre
de réformes et a été institué le comité
des états généraux comité indépendant
comme vous l'avez rappelé présidée par
le président sauvez notre rapport était
prêt fin avril
nous l'avons remis au président de la
république le 8 juillet et depuis le
garde des sceaux a lancé de vastes
consultations
auprès des professionnels de justice le
comité des états généraux a pris
connaissance de l'ensemble des
contributions s'est déplacé en
juridiction pour mesurer la réalité des
juridictions y compris lors d'audiences
de comparution immédiate il a été
présent lors d'ateliers notamment de
convergence il a rencontré à plusieurs
reprises les présidents des groupes de
travail il s'est emparée d'un certain
nombre de thèmes qu'il n'était pas dans
la lettre de mission
comme la responsabilité des décideurs
publics ou un thème aussi extrêmement
importants comme l'accès au droit et
l'accès à la citoyenneté comme vous
l'avez indiqué monsieur le président
alors que les travaux du comité commencé
il ya eu cette tribune des magistrats
des greffiers auxquels se sont joints un
certain nombre d'avocats et les moyens
de la justice ont rentré en force dans
la problématique des états généraux même
s'ils étaient extrêmes présent le
constat du comité extrêmement sévère il
ya un certain nombre de propositions qui
sont faites mais je pense que dans le
rapport du comité le constat est au
moins aussi important que les
propositions parce qu'il faut changer
complètement notre état d'esprit notre
façon de voir et comme vous l'avez dit
arrêtez de réformer sectoriellement il
ya eu un empilement de réformes depuis
une trentaine d'années beaucoup de
nouveaux de réformes ont été essayées et
ça ne fonctionne pas il ya des éléments
très importants qui ont été rappelés
dans le prologue des états généraux
c'est que la justice est un service
public on évoque souvent le service
public de la justice mme on évoque
beaucoup moins souvent le fait que la
justice c'est une autorité judiciaire
qui participe de la démocratie et de
l'état de droit ce que je n'ai pas
indiqué c'est que les juridictions
administratives n'était pas dans le
périmètre des états généraux uniquement
les juridictions de l'ordre judiciaire
en tout cas le constat qui a été portée
c'est qu'il ya une crise majeure de
l'institution judiciaire qui n'a plus
les moyens de remplir son rôle et qui
fait l'objet de remises en questions
multiples est l'une des explications et
il tient au fait de politiques publiques
défaillante alors la justice une justice
au bord de la rupture
nous avons eu beaucoup de statistiques
on voit que les affaires civiles
nouvelles diminue mais pourtant les
délais s'allongent ont donc c'est une
question que s'est posée la cour des
comptes c'est une question que nous nous
sommes posée dans un contexte où il y a
une sur médiatisation de la justice
pénale alors que la justice civile
représente 60% des contentieux des
juridictions de l'ordre judiciaire donc
une justice civile en grande difficulté
une justice qui n'arrivent pas à
protéger les plus faibles que sont
les mineurs en danger que sont les
personnes sous tutelle dans un contexte
de population vieillissante une grande
difficulté pour les parquets qui sera
évoqué tout à l'heure une grande
difficulté pour le système pénitentiaire
qu'il s'agisse du milieu fermé ou du
milieu ouvert
les justiciables considère et ça a été
rappelé dans les travaux menés par le
sénat notamment une grande enquête qui a
été fait il ya à peu près un an sur la
perte de confiance des justiciables dans
la justice où il apparaissait que plus
de 50% des justiciables ne croyait plus
entre guillemets dans la justice pour
les professionnels c'est une perte de
sens c'est à dire une un questionnement
même sur le rôle de l'institution
judiciaire
comme je l'indiquais il ya eu beaucoup
de réformes il ya des moyens qui ont été
donnés à la justice c'est indéniable ces
dernières années mais en dépit de tout
cela ça ne fonctionne pas et surtout en
dépit d'un engagement extrêmement forte
des magistrats et des fonctionnaires de
justice et le constat que nous avons
fait c'est qu'il n'y a jamais eu ou
rarement eu une approche que l'on a
qualifié de systémiques mais une
approche globale ça toujours été une
approche sectorielle par exemple on se
rend compte que le l'application des
peines que la prise en charge des peines
par le juge de l'application des peines
ne fonctionne pas toujours très bien
qu'il faut attendre un certain temps
donc l'idée ça a été de qu'il y ait une
une procédure qui permette aux tribunaux
correctionnels d'aménager les peines à
l'audience en fait ça ne fonctionne pas
très bien pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'il ya trop de dossiers à l'audience
et que les audiences sont tardives donc
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres mais cet
exemple montre qu'il y a vraiment des
essais depuis de nombreuses années de
réformer l'institution judiciaire on n'y
arrive pas parce qu en en examine qu'une
toute petite partie du problème et
notamment il y a quelques années on a
voulu déjudiciariser très rapidement le
comité des états généraux s'est rendu
compte que c'était impossible d'aller
plus loin dans la déjudiciarisation pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'on n'a pas
d'outil de pilotage d'outils
statistiques dignes de ce nom qui
permette de savoir s'ils ont des
judiciarise par exemple les pensions
alimentaires combien ça représente de
dossiers alors qu'on sait que ça
représente 25 % des dossiers en matière
civile autre constat que nous avons fait
qui est très important un pilotage
administratif et budgétaire
déficient un sous-investissement
chronique en particulier en ce qui
concerne
l'informatique avec des applications
obsolètes et une inflation de textes
dans notre rapport on a évoqué le nombre
de réformes concernant notamment le code
pénal le code de procédure pénale dès
qu'il ya un problème dans la société il
ya un texte mais c'est un empilement de
textes est souvent un problème
d'application de la loi dans le temps au
moins en matière civile donc après ce
constat sévère des propositions ont été
faites il y à la question des moyens que
nous avons chiffré
2500 non 1500 magistrat deux mille cinq
cents fonctionnaires
des adjoints administratifs en support
aussi d informer des applications
informatiques et 2500
juriste assistant mais ces moyens ne
suffisent pas parce que il faut
clarifier le rôle de la justice dans la
société l'un des écueils fondamental de
toutes les réformes jusqu'à présent
sauf ce avait été vue un rapport de la
commission des lois du sénat c'est à
quoi sert un juge à quoi sert un avocat
à quoi sert un procureur de la
république quel est son son office quel
est le fils d'un greffier et on a mesuré
dans le rapport d du comité a
quelquefois l'office du juge civil avait
changé c'est à dire qu'au 19e siècle
d'un juge qui appliquée et tranchées et
qui appliquait la loi qui tranchait sont
bons le juge continue à le faire mais il
ya un office extrêmement important du
juge actuellement qui est un office
protecteur c'est à dire des audiences de
cabinet sans robe est très proche du
citoyen et c'est cette justice là qui
est critiquée par les citoyens comme
étant trop lente
peut-être trop soeur également donc la
première question avant toute réforme
c'est qu'elle est l'office du juge
qu'elle est l'office des professionnels
du droit et une fois qu'on y voie clair
on peut procéder à des réformes des
réformes institutionnelles
le rapport du comité des états généraux
donc ça n'engage que moi c'est pas un
rapport révolutionnaire en ce sens qu'on
n'a pas proposé un conseil de justice
comme ça existe dans beaucoup de pays on
n'a pas proposé une séparation du siège
et du parquet comme cela existe dans
beaucoup de pays c'est un rapport
pragmatique mais qui est des
révolutionnaires par son approche qui
est une approche d'ensemble donc pas de
conseils de justice proposer un pour
administrer les biens d'injustice mais
une évolution du rôle du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
une ré articulations de la
responsabilité politique
responsabilité pénale une augmentation
des ressources de la justice qui est
absolument indispensable
l'équipe autour du magistrat on en parle
beaucoup
il y a eu un rapport déposé par madame
dominique le teint qui était membre du
conseil constitutionnel sur l'équipe
autour du magistrat mais qu'il que l'un
des aspects de la réforme c'est pas tout
c'est pas parce qu'il y aura une équipe
autour du magistrat que l'ensemble des
problèmes de la justice sera solutionné
des propositions sur le recrutement dans
la magistrature des propositions sur
l'informatique dont il est urgent de
faire évoluer les systèmes faire évoluer
les organisations territoriales
nous n'avons pas été partisan de
supprimer des juridictions c'est pas du
tout dans cet esprit là on croit
beaucoup à la justice de proximité en
même temps à la spécialisation des
contentieux
l'idée c'était plutôt de faire évoluer
les organisations d'un point de vue
budgétaire le rapport du sénat l'avait
dit en 2017 y ait eu un rapport
également de la cour des comptes un
point également important c'est
l'éducation droit et la politique
d'accès au droit nous avons mesuré à
quel point dans les établissements
scolaires il y à une éducation à la
citoyenneté qui est prévu mais ce que
nous avons mesuré c'est que dans les
faits pour des raisons conjoncturelles
cette éducation n'est pas forcément très
efficiente et il ya un certain nombre de
propositions qui sont faites et aussi
une proposition très importante que
l'institution judiciaire communique
mieux nous avons la culture de
l'obligation de réserve et
collectivement nous communiquons assez
mal sur ce que nous faisons
peut-être pour terminer mon intervention
un focus sur la justice civile ce qui
est marquant dans l'institution
judiciaire sait qu'il y a très peu
d'observateurs
capable d'observer sur une période de 30
ans les grandes évolutions une grande
évolution il y a trente ans il n'y avait
pratiquement que des magistrats
civilistes actuellement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de magistrats pénaliste est de
moins en moins de magistrats civilistes
dans un contexte où il ya eu un large
accès de la justice à la justice du
quotidien donc beaucoup de contentieux
numériquement important qu'on peut
qualifier aussi de contentieux de masse
mais qui humainement sont très complexes
à gérer c'est ce que j'ai évoqué ce sont
les audiences de cabinet ce qui fait que
l'aspect spécialisation des magistrats
pour les matières complexe et de moins
en mois important des magistrats étant
très pris par la justice du quotidien
sauf à la cour d'appel de paris
essentiellement un peu à versailles il
souffre à la cour de cassation justice
civile dans les juridictions de première
instance représente 60% du contentieux
en cours d'appel 75 à 80% et danser 60 k
et le dense et 75 à 80% le contentieux
social en cours d'appels représente la
moitié du contentieux avec un très fort
taux d'appel des conseils des
prud'hommes la justice celle en civil
s'est lentement dégradée depuis une
quinzaine d'années en raison de
multiples facteurs il y a eu un
excellent rapport de l'inspection
générale de la justice a malheureusement
qui n'a pas été rendu publics sur
l'attractivité des fonctions civiles qui
exposent l'ensemble de la problématique
les causes sont multiples à une
pénalisation de la société
les le fait qu' il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de contentieux
numériquement important que devait
traiter les juridictions dans un
contexte de sous dotation importante de
la justice l'ensemble de ces facteurs et
comme conséquence il y a trente ans
pratiquement toutes les audiences
étaient collégial en première instance
et actuellement c'est essentiellement du
juge unique et des contenus de la carte
judiciaire
il ya beaucoup de petites juridictions
de petites structures ou des jeunes
magistrats préside l'audience civile ou
statues seul en matière civile donc le
comité des états généraux a proposé de
redonner la priorité à la première
instance ce qui n'est plus le cas
actuellement avec un taux d'appel qui
peut varier de 14 à 60 70 % en matière
pénale qui est une vraie politique
publique civile à mettre en place on
parle beaucoup de la politique pénale
mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'un garde des
sceaux était entendu par les commissions
des lois sur la politique civile menée
au ministère de la justice un élément
également important développer les modes
alternatifs de règlement des différends
les modes alternatifs ça n'est pas un
pis-aller pour traiter les stocks dans
les juridictions c'est une vraie
politique et sortir de cette culture du
conflit que nous avons souvent en france
et nous avons pas cette démarche
première de la conciliation et de la
médiation pour résumer ce rapport c'est
d'avoir une vision globale quand on
réforme de se poser les questions sur
quels lots fils d'un juge d'un procureur
d'un avocat de ne plus réformé par
secteur et de changer totalement de
l'état d'esprit et si on ne fait pas moi
enfin je ne s'engagent que moi ce que je
vais dire c'est que la crise était déjà
importante il ya dix ans et elle ne fait
que s'aggraver et plus ça continuera
plus la crise s'aggravera si on n'a pas
cette idée globale de réforme de
l'institution il ya beaucoup de parties
prenantes yale gouvernement il ya le
parlement il ya les professionnels du
droit les citoyens et ce qui est très
compliqué c'est que tout le monde
ensemble hi dans la même direction
merci mais à présent temps de passer la
parole à monsieur menace de vous
indiquer quand même que notre audition
et retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat pour chacun le sache
et qu'elle s'inscrit aussi dans la
préparation du débat sur la justice que
nous aurons lui ans qui aura lu en
séance publique le 4 octobre prochain
donc on est aussi dans cette logique
monsieur le procureur général
merci monsieur le président je m'inscris
sans aucune réserve dans ce que viens de
vous dire
madame à reims en préambule j'aurais
peut-être souligné d'ailleurs sous votre
contrôle puisque vous en faisiez partie
que l'exercice n'allait pas de soi je
pense que ça a été un exercice de
qualité un exercice riches un exercice
qu'elle ait pas de soi parce qu'il y
avait quand même un certain nombre de
personnalités très différentes au sein
du comité des hauts fonctionnaires des
magistrats des personnalités politiques
des avocats un ambassadeur des
professeurs
c'était pas évident mais pour autant je
pense qu'on a toujours assisté à des
vins de qualité il n'y a jamais eu
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire un
jour dans un périodique de querelles de
chiffonniers c'est totalement faux et la
preuve en est que comme toujours dans ce
genre de
travail il ya des sujets plus ou moins
clivant tout le monde aura pu noter qu'
il ya des sujets qui ont pu faire
l'unanimité il ya des sujets qui ont
donné lieu à des opinions majoritaires
minoritaires il n'y a jamais eu c'est un
exemple à mon avis qui est assez forte
d'expression d'opinions dissidentes par
rapport à certaines conclusions ce qui
montre quand même un socle minimal de
consensus sur la fois la méthode et puis
le résultat auquel je n'ai pas retenus
je vais vous parlez moi très rapidement
de la procédure pénale qui n'est pas je
dis les choses très franchement le sujet
j'allais dire le plus riche en terme de
propositions formulées mais ça
s'explique très bien je vais essayer de
vous dire pourquoi on ne peut je pense
lire les conclusions du rapport du
comité qu'à la lumière des conclusions
du groupe de travail procédures pénales
dont il faut dire que sans vouloir
prendre toutes les propositions qu'il
avait formulées il s'était prononcé est
lui aussi dans sa majorité pour le
maintien du juge d'instruction avec
toutefois une proposition assez
innovante qui consistait à créer un
nouveau cadre d' enquête à travers une
comparution fait aux fins d'une enquête
complémentaire qui aurait permis au
parquet en cours dans quête de faire
déférer la personne devant lui de lui
notifier un certain nombre de charges de
l'interroger et puis après de poursuivre
l' enquête sur le contrôle il y avait
aussi un certain nombre de propositions
pour rénover les délais d'instruction
pour parachever le contradictoire pour
améliorer la qualité de l'investigation
exemple passer la durée de la flagrance
à 15 jours au lieu de huit jours et puis
enfin
nouvelle mesure phare dans l'évolution
des pouvoirs conférés au parquet c'était
la création d'une mesure transactionnel
qui aurait permis avec l'accord de la
personne concernée de
d2 décidé de mettre en oeuvre des
mesures qu'on va des mesures
transactionnel avec notamment des
amendes composition qui aurait pu donc
être mise en avant avec l'accord de la
personne poursuivie
et ont cas contraire de revenir dans les
modes classiques d'orientation des
poursuites
le comité donc c'est s'est donc
prononcée par par rapport à tout ça et
s'en aller dans le détail de certaines
des mesures qui avaient été proposées
par le groupe de travail a voulu
attachés sont proclamés son attachement
un certain nombre de choses vous noterez
que
les polémiques sur la réforme la police
judiciaire n'avait pas encore commencé
lorsqu'on a travaillé la première
accroche de la procédure pénale dans
notre rapport a consisté à marquer
l'attachement du comité au respect du
principe de la direction de la police
judiciaire par les magistrats
c'est quelque chose qui prend plus
d'actualité depuis quelques semaines
c'est effectivement un principe à valeur
constitutionnelle donc c'est
effectivement important de le rappeler
le comité a surtout voulu assumer une
différence forte par rapport à ce qui
avait été dans le groupe de travail
c'est autour de cette notion de
simplification il a pris à son compte le
fait que la complexification à laquelle
on assiste depuis 20 ans à la procédure
pénale
résulte d'abord et en partie d'un
renforcement des garanties des droits et
que si bien sûr l'architecturé la
visibilité du code de procédure pénale
peuvent peuvent et doivent être
améliorées
la simplification ne peut pas déboucher
sur un affaiblissement de ces garanties
et qu'en particulier la présomption
d'innocence le droit au procès équitable
le délai raisonnable les droits de la
défense ne pourrait pas se trouver
écornée ou diminuer au prétexte d'une de
l'année c'est d'une nécessaire
simplification du code de procédure
pénale c'est toute la limite
effectivement de cet impératif de de
simplification
le groupe de travail à je le le comité a
donc estimé c'est une des grandes idées
c'est ce qui explique peut-être que
c'est une contrôle de mes collègues on
ait pu pas pu aller trop trop loin dans
la réflexion le comité a estimé que
il y avait
il est est aujourd'hui indispensable de
refondre le code de procédure pénal dit
bien refondre c'est le mot qu'on
employés c'est quelque chose je pense
qu'il va au-delà de la simple dimension
codification simplification
même si on a estimé qu'une simple
rokodiva codification à droit constant
constituent à elles fait le chantier mme
pluriannuel on a donc on s'est donc tous
accordés sur le fait que ce code été
frappée aujourd'hui par son inadéquation
qu'ils étaient devenus illisibles et peu
praticables on a évoqué notamment
l'évolution entre 2008 2022 14 ans un
code qui passe de 1700 article à 2400
donc 700 articles de plus en 14 ans ce
qui est quand même considérable donc peu
de lisibilité
problème de cohérence et nécessité d'une
grande stabilité
qui conduit en réalité là aussi c'est
quelque chose qui revient souvent à un
travaux du comité qui conduit à la
nécessité d'inscrire de s'inscrire dans
une démarche systémique qui s'attache au
fond des choses avec une vision globale
et qui amène à s'inscrire dans une
logique de long terme compte tenu des
délais problème de réécriture c'est ce
que nous avons nous avons repris à notre
compte et c'est un avis du groupe de
travail que le comité a donc entièrement
partagé donc on a délibéré sur nombre de
questions essentielles que devrait
trancher le nouveau code de procédure
pénale heures la première qui a donné
lieu à une opinion majoritaire c'est le
maintien du juge d'instruction
je pense qu'on a tous eu conscience il
ya eu d'ailleurs des opinions là dessus
que on vit dans un paysage quelqu'un
assez particulier puisqu'il ya trois
cadres dans quête qui et d'investigation
qui coexiste avec l' enquête
préliminaire elle enquête en flagrance
et l'instruction avec 97 % des dossiers
qui sont traitées par le parquet une
instruction qui ne rassemble plus que 3%
des affaires est donc un cadre j'allais
dire juridique dans lequel dans lequel
on s'inscrit et qui voit que les droits
des gens et les procédures ne sont pas
identiques dans chacun de ces trois
cadres denquête on est
malgré tout c'est pas une unanimité mais
c'est une c'est une majorité on a
manifesté notre attachement à l'office
du juge d'instruction dont on a voulu
souhaiter dont on a voulu affirmer
souligne l expertise la réactivité et
l'efficacité
un particulièrement dans les domaines de
du des affaires criminelles de la grande
criminalité du terrorisme et de la
criminalité cyber et de la criminalité
financière
le il nous a aussi
il nous a aussi paru évident que le
la disparition du juge d'instruction
serait d'autant plus difficile à mettre
en oeuvre au profit finalement d'un
ministère public dont tout le monde
s'accorde à reconnaître que ces
garanties statutaires sont insuffisantes
et ce serait effectivement problématique
de remplacer le fils d'un juge par un
parquetier qui ne bénéficient pas
effectivement des dmm du même statut
donc là aussi je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est frappée du bon sens et qui
donc s'est traduit par une opinion
majoritaire au sein du comité le comité
en réalité a voulu défendre on oppose
toujours le système accusatoire au
système inquisitoire
on est en france dans un système mixte
qui finalement emprunte à la fois un
modèle inquisitoire au modèle
accusatoire on a voulu défendre ce
modèle mixte qui nous paraît garantir
une part importante du contradictoire
dans la phase préparatoire au procès
pénal et qui nous paraît être celui
aussi qui garantit le mieux j'allais
dire les cas l'idée l'égalité des droits
et l'accès à la justice contrairement à
d'autres systèmes je pense notamment
système américain où l'égalité est loin
d'être être d'être identique on a estimé
dans le cadre de ce maintien du juge
d'instruction
que n'était pas souhaitable la création
de la nouvelle procédure intermédiaire
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui était
souhaité par
le groupe de travail donc créé un
nouveau cap dans kate avec une enquête
complémentaire on a estimé que ça risque
de complexifier encore davantage les
cadres juridiques existants et que pour
cette raison ça n'était donc pas
souhaitable on a aussi estimé que compte
tenu du fonctionnement de la justice on
ne pouvait pas se priver aujourd'hui
d'une réflexion de fond sur la question
de la tenue des audiences de
comparutions immédiates qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs dans les mécanismes qui
ils sont aussi pour qu'ils expliquent
aussi au moins en partie la
surpopulation pénitentiaire à travers
l'augmentation des peines de prison qui
sont données contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire à travers un défaut
procédé procès d'intention qu'on entend
souvent sur laxisme de la justice 1 les
peines de prison dans leurs moyennes ont
augmenté de quasiment deux mois en
l'espace de quelques années donc là
aussi ça tord le cou à ce reproche là
pour autant il ya un vrai sujet sur ces
audiences de comparution immédiate à
travers effectivement le recours à des
procédures de plus en plus rap de plus
en plus rapide et à des audiences dont
un certain nombre d'acteurs on
soulignait le caractère tardif et les
mauvaises conditions qui fait dans
lesquelles effectivement la justice
pénale pouvaient être amenés à
fonctionner a fonctionné aujourd'hui on
a aussi souhaité une réflexion sur le
déroulement de l'audience devant le
tribunal criminel départemental dans le
cadre de la réécriture du code de
procédure pénale ça prend aussi du sens
puisque effectivement on était sur un
schéma d'expérimentation qui a été
finalement clos avant de venir au terme
l'expérimentation et qui s'est traduit
par la généralisation donc je pense que
cette appréciation pour un certain
relief au regard effectivement de la
précipitation
et en tout cas la l'accélération du
processus qui a été choisi par le
législateur enfin ça aussi c'est quelque
chose d'assez fort le comité je crois
d'ailleurs sous le contrôle de mes
collègues je crois qu'il ya une
quasiment une unanimité là dessus on a
pas estimé souhaitable d'aller encore
plus loin dans les pouvoirs donnés au
parquet on trouve que au regard des
équilibres institutionnels auxquels on
arrive aujourd'hui des garanties
statutaires du ministère public il nous
a pas paru opportun est souhaitable
d'aller encore plus loin et d'aller
jusqu'à conférer la décision à la mise
en oeuvre par le ministère public d'une
mesure d'ordre transactionnel on pense
que ça ne pourrait que venir brouiller
encore davantage le paysage
institutionnel et brouiller encore
davantage
l'office du parc et l'office du juge
dernière chose que je soulignerai et en
ayant encore une fois conscience des
limites mais elle s'explique très bien
on n'a pas su en réalité tout comme
d'ailleurs le groupe de travail résoudre
le choix qui pouvait s'opérer entre un
certain nombre de modèles et notamment
un certain nombre de cadres dans 400 et
notamment une grande question qui s'est
posée à la fois au groupe e au comité
est-ce qu'il faut
fusionner les cadres d' enquête bon il
ya bien sûr le maintien ou la
suppression du juge d'instruction mais
faut-il ou pas je suis peut fusionner
les cadres en quête de la flagrance et
de l' enquête préliminaire et si on les
fusionne dans quel sens faut-il aller
faut-il aller vers la généralisation du
cadre de l enquête préliminaire ou au
contraire ce que souhaitent certains ou
faut-il au contraire aller ce que ce
soit d'autre comme notamment le
directeur général la police nationale
lorsqu'on a entendu fusionner pour que
on est un seul cadre qui serait
l'enquète de flagrance on n'a pas
pu et souhaité répondre à cette question
parce que on se rend compte que quand on
pousse les feux de la réflexion on n'a
pas en réalité aujourd'hui d'éléments
suffisants en termes d'études d'impact
sur les conséquences précises et
profonde que pourrait comporter le choix
d'une solution ou de l'autre donc on a
estimé ça aussi c'est pas pour le comité
une façon de se défausser c'est au
contraire j'allais dire une preuve
sérieux dans lequel il du sérieux de sa
réflexion le comité a estimé qu'il était
absolument aujourd'hui indispensable
avant tout réécriture du code de
procédure pénale d'avoir mise en oeuvre
par le ministère de la justice une étude
d'impact qui soit extrêmement fouillée
et approfondie pour qu on mesure bien
les conséquences de ces choix parce que
les questions paraissent faciles on
s'aperçoit en réalité que le diable se
niche véritablement dans les détails et
que c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
en a l'air donc ça nous semble
effectivement un exercice préalable qui
doit venir intervenir avant toute
réflexion de fond sur effectivement une
auquel pourrait conduire une réécriture
voilà je ne suis pas exhaustif dans tout
ce que ce que j'ai dit j'ai essayé de
vous résumer l'ensemble effectivement
des des réflexions sur un plan général
du code je suis pas rentré dans le
détail il ya aussi je ne veux pas
aborder un serbe de choses qui sont dans
le groupe de travail pro / pénale qui
sont en réalité d'un quand on regarde
bien mais ça je pense que la commission
des lois le c'est beaucoup mieux que moi
on retrouve un certain nombre de mesures
que certains acteurs avaient essayé de
mettre dans la loi de 2019 et qui sont
restés à la porte effectivement qui
n'ont pas été repris par le vent les
parlementaires donc je pense qu'il ya
des choses que certains ont voulu
essayer de remettre dans le dans le dans
la seringue
je veux pas perdre de temps à revenir
sur ces choses que tout le monde connaît
dont vous avez déjà eu l'occasion de
parler je remercie notre attention
générale la parole à m gavaudo qui est
le président du conseil national des
barreaux merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames messieurs
quelques quelques éléments simplement
sans rallonge et là je souscris à ce qui
a été dit par madame la première
présidente et monsieur le procureur
général il y a rien à dire je voudrais
faire trois observations la première sur
le pelouse le contexte et l'état
d'esprit qui a été rappelé par madame la
première présidente dans lesquelles se
sont sont inscrits ces états généraux et
le travail effectué par le comité des
états généraux
qui est un comité totalement indépendant
et nous avons tenu à cette indépendance
l'état d'esprit qui a amené nos travaux
et qui finalement a non seulement mené
de trop mais c'est celui que nous avons
recueillies et des personnes que nous
avons entendues et même des groupes de
travail est assez à contre courant de ce
qui ce qui s'est fait jusqu'à présent
dans le cadre des réformes de la justice
j'ai le souvenir il ya pas si longtemps
pour la réforme qui avait été menée par
mme belloubet dans cette même salle sur
un certain nombre d'auditions que votre
commission qu'achille n'apprendrez rien
de ce que nous souffrions d'une vision
utilitariste du système judiciaire
déjudiciarisation
conciliation obligatoire par voire de
légal tech payante faisant fi à la fois
de la fracture numérique et puis de de
l'incapacité du citoyen à connaître
comment saisir éventuellement une
juridiction voir un médiateur on
craignait les problématiques de carte
judiciaire de suppression des
juridictions qu'on voulait spécialisés
de manière départementale ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire craindre
l'assèchement d'un certain nombre de
matières dans certaines juridictions et
donc leur dévitalisation total
le le juge le stakhanoviste l'avocat
renvoyer dent c'est dans ses cordes
d'auxiliaires de justice qui doit se
plier à une procédure civile de plus en
plus compliqué bref nous étions dans
l'utilitarisme les les réflexions les
travaux à partir d'ailleurs de ce qui a
été
présenté au président de la république
par le madame la présidente après un
présidente et monsieur procureur général
était tout autre à un conte stade de
quasi épuisement qui a été admis qui a
été acceptée un manque de moyens c'est
pas c'est pas simplement sur ce point
que nous avons travaillé mais il fallait
que ce constat soit dressé une détresse
d une détresse des magistrats qui
tiennent et des personnels de grève des
greffiers qui tiennent l'institution
judiciaire et aux miroirs aussi la
souffrance qui a été exprimée qui a pu
valablement s'est exprimée par les
professionnels du droit et en premier
les avocats qui effectivement sont elles
aussi
potentiellement les victimes de cette de
cette dégradation l'état d'esprit aussi
était intéressant parce que pour la
première fois du côté de la magistrature
je crois que c'est important de le de le
dire à votre votre commission il ya eu
la reconnaissance de cette difficulté
pas simplement des juges de terrain
pardon mais aussi des chefs de
juridiction qui connaissent bien le
terrain c'est parce que je veux dire
qu'ils ont admis effectivement qui est
au bout d'un moment on n'arrivait plus à
on n'aurait plus à tenir et qu'il
fallait un peu de souplesse un peu de
liberté un peu de moyens un peu de deux
possibilités de réorganiser de
réorganiser les choses ça a été admis et
je crois que c'est un point très
important et puis aussi la conviction
que tout cela se fait non pas pour
l'institution judiciaire non pas pour
l'autorité judiciaire on a beaucoup les
uns les autres insisté sur le fait qu'il
s'agissait bien d'une autorité et qui si
elle est malmenée à des impacts sur la
respiration de la démocratie on vient
vous l'avez rappelé madame la première
présidente mais c'est un point important
une justice malmené c'est une justice
qui n'est plus indépendante un juge qui
ne peut pas trancher parce qu'il n'a pas
les moyens en matière civile qu'en
matière pénale c'est une justice qui n'a
plus d'indépendance tout ça a été tout
ça a été évoqué et c'était important
parce que le coeur de nos préoccupations
c'est la fin de mon premier point
c'était comme ça l'est pour vous je
pense le justiciable et les
présentations qui sont faites sont assez
techniques parce que nous sommes
finalement des techniciens mais ce qui a
mené nos débats essentiellement c'est
vraiment le citoyen et la république sur
la sur la sp cet état d'esprit a permis
de libérer un certain nombre de sujets
en matière de procédure civile je pense
que mais là aussi c'est pas tellement
nouveau mais ça a été finalement acté il
faut s'intéresser à la justice civile il
faut lui donner les moyens il faut
s'intéresser aux juges il faut avoir on
a beaucoup travaillé sur ces questions
là d'un aspect sociologique c'est à dire
quels sont les profils des magistrats
qui sortent de l'école nationale de la
magistrature
quels sont les profils des magistrats
qui vont être intégrés dans la
magistrature les jeunes sont ils encore
en capacité ou ont-ils le souhait ou
l'énergie de travailler et de tenir des
audiences correctionnelles jusqu'à 23
heures tout ça ce sont des éléments qui
ont été
acte est entendue et sur lequel on a
nous avons nous avons nous avons avancé
réforme de la procédure civile
éventuellement réforme de la procédure
d'appel qui peut se faire par voie
réglementaire nous l'avons évoqué il ya
eu consensus aussi sur ces questions là
non pas pour libérer la possibilité d
avocats de multiplier les actes de
procédure mais parce que effectivement
s'aperçoit que les chausse trapes
procédurales ne permettent pas de gagner
du temps ou d'avancé repositionné le
magistrat redonner de la valeur au juge
de première instance toute chose qui
méritait d'être qui méritait d'être dit
et puis aussi en tout cas pour la
profession d'avocat rappelé que pour
nous l'office du juge est très important
qui avoir des réflexions sur le fils du
juge mais que nous préférons toujours
que ce soit le juge qu' au total décide
pas simplement tranche le litige mais
aussi soit le maître de l'organisation
judiciaire et je crois que c'était très
important parce que c'était très nouveau
vous avez évoqué la première présidente
la question des modes alternatifs de
règlement des différends au des litiges
c'est vrai que on a admis que ce n'était
pas un la panacée et que les modes de
règlement des différends ne sont pas là
pour éviter la saisine du juge ils sont
là pour accompagner le justiciable et
d'ailleurs nous nous essayons dans la
profession d'avocat de désormais éviter
le terme qui va encore changer de mode
alternatif de règlement des différends
pour dire des modes de règlement des
différends il faut que nous changions
nous mêmes nos pratiques notre vision
des choses c'est pas alternatif c'est à
côté de la saisine de la saisine du juge
sur la procédure pénale jeunes ans je
n'en rajoute pas ce qui était très
important aussi dans nos débats et c'est
important de le dire ici dans cette
commission des lois très attachés aux
libertés publiques et individuelles
il n'a jamais été question et pour nous
c'était très important d'en donner pas
sur le juge d'instruction nos débats sur
le sur la sûreté sur la procédure sur
les enquêtes dans nos débats sur une
éventuelle réforme du code de procédure
c'est mal pénale dans nos débats sur les
traitements
des notamment d'aider matière
correctionnelle ce qui était très
important
c'était le citoyen
le présumé innocent les droits de la
défense et sous l'autorité judiciaire et
pas par exemple une autorité
administrative
nous avons aujourd'hui peut-être de nous
dirions différemment mais nous avons
aussi évoqué la place du parquet mais
aussi la place de la police
administrative et non je confirme ce que
vient de dire le procureur général nous
n'avions pas exprimé nous n'aurions
exprimé différemment mais en tout cas
nous sommes tous très attachés c'est un
consensus à ce que la police judiciaire
soit effectivement attaché aux
magistrats parce que ce sont eux qui
sont d'abord et avant tout les garants
des libertés individuelles
merci monsieur le président avant de
donner la parole aux présidents sauvé
drame rappelé par an en tête un chiffre
qui date de 2010 9 la justice civile
c'est plus de deux millions deux cent
mille décisions
pour l'année 2019 la justice pénale un
peu plus de 800 milles
pour pour distinguer pour bien peser les
choses et l'opinion publique se forment
sur le stis pénal mais c'est important
mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel monsieur
le président sauvez vous avez la parole
il je voudrais d'abord souligner que je
suis complètement d'accord avec mes
collègues qui se sont exprimé auparavant
et qui ne se sont pas exprimées à titre
personnel mais qui ont bien rendu compte
du rapport je me contenterai pour éviter
des redites de quelques notations
d'abord sur la crise de la justice
il faut bien voir que nous sommes dans
notre pays confronté à une double crise
une crise universelle et une crise
nationale
la crise universelle c'est la crise de
l'autorité judiciaire
ce pouvoirs publics constitutionnels
qui est inséparable de la démocratie et
de l'état de droit tout ceci est lié au
rôle croissant du juge dans nos sociétés
le juge appliquer la loi disons
jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle il est
devenu l'interprète de la loi
désormais il les juge de la loi
notamment au travers du contrôle de
conventionnalité nous savons tous qu
aujourd'hui
aucune décision de politique publique ne
peut être prise sans considération
de la manière dont un juge national ou
européen
appréciera cette décision c'est une
expérience quotidienne que nous faisons
y compris par exemple sur la possibilité
de réformer les retraites par la voix de
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour prendre le dernier exemple
le juge en fait qu construit le droit
dans tous les pays et ceux ci introduit
une rupture dans le fonctionnement des
pouvoirs publics ça se traduit par une
judiciarisation de la vie publique en
france et donc tous les états et ceux ci
créée des turbulences et des tensions
dans la totalité des pays je n'en
connais qu'un seul qui souhaitent
épargné par ces turbulences c'est
l'allemagne mais elle a fait une
expérience historique au xxème siècle
qui met l'institution judiciaire tout à
fait à part et incontesté crise de
l'autorité judiciaire crise du service
public de la justice
alors tout a été dit mais je voudrais
quand même souligner qu'elle est très
paradoxal puisque la demande de justice
au cours de la dernière décennie
n'a pas augmenté substantiellement
mais que les dd et les stocks ont
augmenté
donc différentes raisons qui sont
notamment liées à
la complexification du droit et la
difficulté
particulière des affaires voilà ce que
je voudrais dire aussi c'est que
l'allongement des bd nous le constatons
dans le champ civile dans le champ pénal
dans le champ de la juste liste de
protection
qui d'une certaine manière dysfonctionne
également nous avons un retard dans
l'exécution des décisions de la justice
pénale et de protection tous ces points
sont majeurs et je voulais des souligné
et puis il y a un malaise sur une
justice qui est peu compréhensible et
accessible en ce qui concerne le
diagnostic
je vais tout à fait dans le sens de ce
qui est dit la première présidente
nous avons nommé une question qui a été
soigneusement dissimulé je crois par le
pouvoir exécutif au cours des deux
dernières décennies pas dans les
rapports parlementaires
c'est le déficit des moyens
cette insuffisance a été nié
officiellement mais en fait avoué au
travers des tentatives de
déjudiciarisation des 20 dernières
années
le problème qui se pose n'est pas
seulement celui des moyens c'est aussi
celui de l'incapacité à penser la
justice de manière systémique et à la
gérer de manière rationnelle
les réformes de la justice
souvent
utiles dans leur inspiration ont trop
consistait dans un égrenage de mesures
ponctuelles
et au fond on a appliqué
quelques rustines un dispositif qui
s'enfonçait petit à petit
les réformes ont aussi été largement
déconnectée des conditions de leur
application le ministère de la justice
et le temple du légiste entrisme et j'ai
pu constater que 40 ans après
17 années que j'ai passées à la
chancellerie dans les années 80 en
réalité rien n'avait changé
il y a également sur le plan de la
gestion de justice des problèmes des
problèmes majeurs je parle bien sûr
d'une organisation déconcentré kiné qui
n'est pas lisible qui n'est pas
compréhensible mais aussi de
l'insuffisance du management il n'y a
pas de pilotage cohérent de
l'institution il n'y a pas de gestion
des ressources humaines dignes de ce nom
et il faut porter remède à cette
situation
alors quant à la réforme qui est
proposée par le comité quant aux
réformes qui sont proposées par le
comité il faut être au clair sur le
positionnement de la justice dans la
société et par rapport aux autres
pouvoirs publics comme l'a dit
auparavant la première présidente ne
proposons pas de conseils de justice ni
de séparation entre le siège et du
parquet nous ne proposons pas non plus
de remettre en cause le principe de la
gestion administrative et financière de
la justice par le gouvernement sous le
contrôle du parlement mais il ya des
réformes importantes à mener
notamment sur le statut du parquet
cette réforme qui a été envisagé et même
préparé en 2000 moi j'ai soumis au
président de la république
un décret de convocation du congrès et
j'ai dû quelques semaines ensuite
soumettre un deuxième décret de
démontage du congrès c'est la seule fois
dans l'histoire de la république
qu'un tel acte a été pris voilà nous
proposons aussi de revoir un certain
nombre d' équilibre au sein du csm et en
particulier de la commission
d'avancement il faut aussi c'est un
sujet
un peu périphériques mais très sensible
revoir la responsabilité pénale des
décideurs publics en particulier des
membres du gouvernement
il faut supprimer la cour de justice de
la république et aménager les règles de
fond de la responsabilité pénale quand
les actes mis-en-cause découle
directement de la mise en oeuvre par les
ministres c'est leurs collaborateurs de
la politique du gouvernement
je n'insiste pas sur le renforcement
de la première instance la première
présidente a dit tout ce qui était
nécessaire c'est un point fondamental du
rapport je voudrais
souligner de manière plus technique le
besoin de professionnaliser la gestion
des ressources humaines il faut que ces
ressources soient gérés et qu'elle soit
mieux répartie en introduisant une
vision de moyen et long terme avec des
référentiels
d'activité il faut aussi diversifier
le recrutement et ouvrir la formation
des magistrats il faute évaluer et
refonder l'évaluation des chefs de
juridictions évaluer aussi les premiers
présidents de cours d'appel et des
magistrats de la cour de cassation qui
ne le sont pas
bien sûr la stratégie numérique doit
être refondu il faut vraiment on peut
fonder la maîtrise d'ouvragé de ces
applications et renforcer la place du
numérique
dans la conception des réformes est
aussi est aussi dans les directions
métiers du ministère de la justice la
direction des affaires civiles la
direction des affaires criminelles et
pas seulement l'administration
pénitentiaire et la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse par ailleurs
des réformes sectorielles
sont indispensables je ne reviens pas
sur la nécessité de mettre en place une
véritable politique publique de la
justice civile c'est un point
fondamental la justice civile qui
étaient là la première branche de la
justice la plus noble est aujourd'hui
totalement sinistré dans ce contexte là
j'ai oublié sur les réformes statutaires
il est indispensable de séparer le grade
et l'emploi notamment pour permettre de
renforcer la première instance avec des
magistrats
seniors des magistrats cap et
expérimentés
il faut alors pour la justice économique
et sociale nous en avons peu parlé mais
nous avons tout un ensemble de
propositions sur la justice du travail
des conseils de prud'hommes et la
justice commerciale avec
l'expérimentation de tribunaux des
affaires économiques et aussi
l'expérimentation de la participation
des partis au financement de la justice
dans le cadre de la justice économique
voilà sur la procédure pénale le
procureur général a tout dit et je ne
saurais mieux m'exprimer que lui je
voudrais sur les questions
pénitentiaires
rapt et que nous avons pris position
peut-être on ce sera notre rapport
banale sur le sens de la peine c'est un
point qui nous est apparu important
la peine a pour objet de sanctionner des
comportements
déviants elle a aussi pour objet de
préparer la réinsertion
des condamnés et elle a pour objet de
réduire le risque de récidive
dans ce contexte nous ne proposons pas
d'enchaîner les programmes de
construction d'établissements
pénitentiaires
au delà de ceux qui ont été décidées et
qui sont en cours nous proposons de
limiter de manière volontariste le
recours aux courtes peines de renforcer
substantiellement les moyens du milieu
ouvert en évoque la possibilité de créer
une agence du milieu ouvert nous
proposons également pour mieux articuler
le prononcé des peines et leur exécution
de faire revenir les services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et probation
dans les juridictions pour personnaliser
des peines et permettent leur
aménagement effectifs à benicio est
enfin nous proposons pour éviter des
condamnations à répétition pour
traitements inhumains et dégradants de
mettre en place un dispositif de
régulation de la population carcérale
qui
ne soit pas un numerus clausus pure et
simple voilà quelques-unes des
perspectives que nous mettons sur la
table
merci monsieur le président merci à
chacun et chacune est à vous allez me
présenter à vous messieurs des propos
tenus on va ouvrir le débat et je
compose de la parole à madame dominique
vien qui co rapporteurs d'ailleurs avec
mam canayer du budget de la justice
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci à vous quatre de cette
présentation
à la fois synthétique mais quasi
exhaustive de votre rapport
qui était effectivement très intéressant
et qui reprend un certain nombre de
choses comme vous l'avez dit que nous
connaissions mais il est important que
justement ces choses soient dites et
remise
au président de la république et à son
garde des sceaux
j'ai plusieurs questions alors je
reviendrai pas sur l'informatique c'est
un des sujets pour lequel nous
interpellons la chancellerie depuis
depuis longtemps je réserve ma question
lors du pour le débat que nous aurons
sur les états généraux de la justice
dans notre hémicycle mais d'abord je
voulais savoir comment avait été reçu
votre rapport justement et si des
engagements avaient été pris de prendre
en charge
réellement vos préconisations
ensuite alors un sujet qui pourrait
paraître un détail pour vous mais qui
pour nous dans l'yonne veut dire
beaucoup vous l'aurez compris la carte
judiciaire avez vous rencontré les
magistrats et les avocats
justement de l'yonne par rapport à cette
carte puisque si j'ai bien lu le rapport
nous serions attaché à dijon enfin ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle ça fait
longtemps qu'on lutte contre ce
rattachement mais donc voilà avez vous
entendu magistrats et avocats du
département pour cela
vous parle également de réforme de
justice civile et de plus de
collégialité je pense que c'est
effectivement une
très bonne chose est ce que dans cette
collégialité est envisagée le fait de
mieux faire travailler ensemble juge aux
affaires familiales et juge des enfants
qui parfois peuvent mettre quatre mois
pour se passer un dossier alors qu'on
sait bien que justement au niveau d'un
divorce conflictuel les enfants ne sont
pas enfin ce sont des victimes très
claire de ce qui peut se passer est
d'ailleurs à propos de victimes de
violences intrafamiliales puisque si on
parle de choses qui se passent mal dans
le couple je n'ai pas du tout vu une
réflexion sur ce sujet alors
probablement n'étaient-elles pas dans
vos lettres de mission alors que
pourtant j'ai cru comprendre que ça
faisait partie 2
d'une grande cause
du quinquennat passé et du quinquennat
actuel et pour finir puisqu'il faut plus
de moyens avez-vous réfléchi à
introduire du coup plus de magie d'une
plus de mixité dans la magistrature
et quels moyens pour obtenir plus de
mixité dans la magistrature merci merci
madame v rien monsieur jean pierre sueur
je propose de prendre ensuite madame
benbassa et puis monsieur marc philippe
daubresse on donnera à nous à nos
invités la parole puis on recommence
avec madame harribey madame canayer
monsieur bonnecarrère et monsieur le
comte mais le sauna richard qui sera
long mais c'est sûr merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président
madame la première présidente monsieur
le procureur général et monsieur le
président merci pour
ces ce rapport qui est très intéressant
c'est vrai vous avez dit madame la
première présidente que c'était
révolutionnaire
que de ne pas empiler les réformes
que de ne pas s'être sectorielle et qu'
il était aussi tout à fait
révolutionnaire qu'il n'ya pas 700
amendements 700 articles de plus dans
les quatre ou cinq prochaines années ce
qui en quelque sorte un conseil qu'il
nous est amicalement donné je voulais
poser quelques questions concrètes
d'abord la première réaction qui a eu
lieu à la suite de la publication de
votre rapport c'était la question des
moyens vous l'avez dit
le garde des sceaux d'atur helmand fera
valoir il y a eu pour cent
d'augmentation depuis trois ans
nous savons que c'est ce n'est pas
suffisant et que la france reste dans
les dernières places au plan européen
comme au plan de l' ocde par rapport au
pib pour les budget attribué à la
justice est-ce que vous avez envisagé d
solution en particulier ne serait-il pas
raisonnable même si c'est contraire au
principe de l'annualité budgétaire qu'il
y ait une sorte de programmation sur une
dizaine d'années pour rattraper le
retard avec une sorte de
d'injonction qui s'appliquerait à tous
les gouvernements c'est sans doute un
rêve mais je me permet de l'exprimer
deuxièmement pour ce qui est de la
répartition des magistrats entre le
civil et le pénal j'entends bien ce que
vous avez dit quelles solutions
concrètes envisagez-vous pour qu'il y
ait davantage de magistrats civilistes
est ce que vous imaginez des systèmes
qui affecterait des postes qui ferait qu
il y aurait une politique volontariste
dans ce domaine
troisièmement
vous avez dit monsieur le procureur
général
que la réforme de la du tribunal
départemental criminelle avait été fait
dans une certaine précipitation
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas attendu la fin
de l'expérimentation pour généraliser ce
système
quel avenir voyez-vous à ce dispositif
etes-vous toujours partisan je crois
l'avoir lu dans le rapport du jury
populaire sont quoi vous rejoins driller
monsieur le garde des sceaux à l'époque
où il n'était pas garde des sceaux
un autre point sur la surpopulation
pénitentiaire que vous venez de parler
que vous venez d'évoquer vous avez parlé
d'une régulation
que quid comment ça se passe
concrètement la régulation et sans
abuser j'avais une dernière question
dans mon département il ya une maison de
la justice et du droit qui traite à peu
près de 2000
personnes qui viennent par an elle des
vidéoconférences et vite des visions
qui vont dans tous les chefs lieux de
canton c'est géré par une greffière qui
est absolument épuisé par l'ampleur du
travail
pensez vous qu'il y ait un avenir pour
ce genre de str thür je vous remercie
puis monsieur sueur madame est servie
mbassa
merci monsieur le président je vais je
remercie les intervenants pour leur
intervention synthétique est clair et je
voudrais toutefois posé quelques
questions
dans le rapport vous préconisez de
développer davantage le recours aux
travaux d'intérêt général en effet et
cela permet une réponse pénale plus
clair plus efficace et moins coûteuse
cela remplit une fonction de réparation
et de réinsertion c'est une véritable
alternative à l'incarcération
en ce sens y at il un projet de
collaboration à grande échelle entre les
entreprises les structures d'accueil et
les spip une deuxième question le coût
moyen d'une année de prison
pour une personne détenue est estimée et
il me semble à 32000 euros tandis que le
coût moyen annuel d'une mesure en milieu
ouvert et de 10000 et 2014 oh il est
nécessaire alors de recourir à des
alternatives à la détention et qui de
plus
allègerait considérablement le budget de
la justice comment un maître donc en
place et concrètement ces mesures et
quand est ce que la france va rompre
avec la logique du tout carcéral
la loi de finances 2 pour 2022 alloue
aux alternatives à l'incarcération un
budget stagnante à
35,8 millions d'euros contre près d'un
milliard d'euros d'investissement
immobilier pénitentiaire
ne trouvez-vous pas qu'il y ait un
manque d'ambition ou du moins une
répartition est inégale du budget de la
justice je vous remercie merci madame
end à ça et puis pour terminer cette
première série de questions monsieur
marc philippe daubresse
merci monsieur le président nos wii j'ai
une question générale de méthode et une
questions plus ciblées peut-être pour le
procureur général mollahs ce qui
concerne la procédure pénale la première
de méthodes ccl2 qu'on vous ait tous
parlé de réformes systémiques
c'est de constater que il ya une réforme
systémique à l'étude pour la justice
mais qui en même temps
pour reprendre l'expression
présidentielle une réforme systémique de
de l'intérieur et de la police qui se
produit et a une autonomie qui est en
train d'être présenté cette loppsi
devrait faire passer devrait augmenter
de 25% en cinq ans les moyens du
ministère de l'intérieur est évidemment
vous disais avait fait incidemment
allusion évidemment que dans cette loque
mis à des choses qui concernent
directement la justice en particulier la
procédure pénale puisque et une réforme
de la police judiciaire une réforme
générale de la police nationale la
création d'assistant denquête à une
modification du statut d'aidé au pgi
bref là ma question de méthode est la
suivante est ce que vous pensez pas
qu'ils seraient utiles ces balles
s'adresse à peut-être à monsieur sauver
que que le comité généraux des états
généraux de la justice rencontre un
comité d'orientation du bureau de la
sécurité pour essayer de faire une
réforme systémique ensemble ça c'est une
question naïve que je pose la deuxième
question est
est plus ciblée sur monsieur le
procureur général molas et qu' il ne
vous a pas échappé que au mois de
juillet de cette année il y à une
jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
qui cassent finalement
tous les problématiques étaient liées à
la possibilité pour les procureurs
d'aller chercher par exemple des
fadettes en saisissant des opérateurs
téléphoniques sur toute une série
d'infractions et de remonter des
filières de délinquance et que la
législation européenne qui s'impose à la
france
finalement restreint cette possibilité
uniquement à des crimes importants ce
qui fait que les procureurs on a tiré à
plusieurs reprises la conférence des
procureurs notre attention sur le fait
qu' il allait être privé de moyens très
importants
en termes d'efficacité on l'avait vu
avec ma collègue agnès canayer danse à
une législation précédente et à nouveau
puisque nous nous sommes en train de
regarder la loi l'ocme il attire notre
attention sur le fait qu'à un problème
majeur ce qui suppose ray une réforme
soit du statut des magistrats soit de
trouver une solution entre par exemple
les jld qui semble pas être la solution
satisfaisante est-ce que vous avez une
idée sur la manière de sortir de ce
piège qui finalement est en train de
restreindre considérablement le champ
d'action de nos procureurs à un moment
on a besoin de lutter contre la grande
délinquance
merci monsieur daubresse c'est le
président sous laisse le soin de
répartir éventuellement la parole
merci monsieur le président pour
les questions de madame béria la mise en
oeuvre du rapport du comité des états
généraux incombe aux gouvernements sous
le contrôle du parlement
oui
la mise en oeuvre la mise en oeuvre du
rapport du comité des états généraux un
incombe au gouvernement au garde des
sceaux sous le contrôle du parlement
si vous voulez le comité des états
généraux ne va pas usurpée des pouvoirs
qui ne lui appartiennent pas
et maintenant on enfin notre mission
s'est terminée le 8 juillet lorsque nous
présentant le rapport est en réalité
elle s'est terminée le 30 avril lorsque
nous avons achevé la rédaction de ce
document en ce concerne la carte
judiciaire
je ne répondrai pas précisément à la
question qui a été posée sur le
rattachement des juridictions du
département de l'yonne à la cour d'appel
de ils ont ou à la cour d'appel de
bourges mais j'ai compris
que notre rapport avait été compris
je voudrais dire fondamentalement que
nous ne proposons pas de fusion
autoritaire de juridiction ni en
première instance ni en appel et c'est
ça je dirais de la dimension
fondamentale de notre rapport nous ne
considérons pas que le salut de la
justice puisse résulter
d'une
d'une apparente
rationalisation de la carte en ce qui
concerne les rapports entre le juge aux
affaires familiales et juge des enfants
nous sommes extrêmement conscient de la
nécessité
de surmonter des obstacles
incompréhensible à la communication ça
tient à la surcharge des magistrats à la
surcharge des greffes et l
incommunicabilité entre les systèmes
d'information
quand on sait d'ailleurs aussi que ne
communique pas le système enfin du
bureau d'ordre pénal d'une part et le
système de l'application des peines
d'autre part on se rend compte que la
gestion de la justice est aujourd'hui
une tâche quasiment impossible
si on n'a pas une multitude de petites
fiches cartonnées à droite et à gauche
qu'on arrive plus ou moins à classer
dans son bureau en ce qui concerne les
moyens et notamment des moyens humains
je n'ai pas bien compris des questions
de la mixité je pense que
la question de la mixité ne se pose pas
dans l'institution judiciaire
en voile elle se pose peut-être de deux
manières de manière inversée mais le
comité ne recommande pas de numerus
clausus pour garantir
je dirais de l'entrée dans la
magistrature d'hommes
qui serait moins qualifiés moins
méritant que les femmes
voilà donc il faut certainement qui est
un équilibre mais qu'on tienne compte
d'abord du mérite
comment oui monsieur présent je suis pas
certain que cet été que la mixité
sociale m'excite hommes femmes c'était
une mixité sociale à cet égard est une
proposition d'intégration et c'est un
été très favorable jeudi pour la pour la
profession d'avocat c'est
qu'effectivement on déjà il ya déjà une
forme de mixité c'est à dire qu'on
s'aperçoit que un taux important de
magistrats composent la magistrature
sans avoir était 100 ans sans être passé
par l'école nationale de magistrature la
moitié m'a dit madame à reims et puis il
ya des propositions qui sont faites
d'ailleurs on en parle avec le garde des
sceaux pour fluidifier effectivement là
notamment avec la profession d'avocat
l'intégration
pour répondre à madame la sénatrice j'ai
le sentiment quand même que au niveau du
recrutement en tout cas les codes
administrateurs la mixité sociale si
c'est de ça dont vous vouliez parler par
exemple est semble-t-il est semble-t-il
assuré comme elle l'est dans toutes les
professions du droit si c'est et des
profils aussi puisque jeunes indiqué
iliad et d'autres professionnels du
droit qui intègre et la magistrature
tout au long de la tout au long de l'a2
de l'avis des palais de justice
si vous permettait là dessus le comité a
proposé une réforme de la composition de
la commission d'avancement de mémoire
avec effectivement vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui elle est composée que de
magistrats
il n'aurait fait une composition rénovée
avec des magistrats et des non
magistrats pourrait peut-être
effectivement contribuer à diversifier
les intégrations c'est ça c'est quelque
chose qui est un problème qui se posera
nécessairement puisque à partir du
moment où mr a annoncé plus 1500
magistrats sur cinq ans ces gens là il
va falloir les recrutés par l'école bien
sûr mais nécessairement par
l'intégration parce que les possibilités
on peut pas pousser les murs à le n 1 à
bordeaux non il y aura forcément des
recrutements le cadre de carrières plus
courtes à la commission d'avancement
d'où l'intérêt effectivement d'avoir une
commission rénovée et qui statuent
suivant des procédures rénové pour plus
d'efficacité dans la mixité et d'heures
et dans les délais d'instruction
merci j'en viens aux questions de
présidence sueur en ce qui concerne les
moyens additionnels dont la justice doit
être doté
le comité de manière tout à fait
consciente et délibérée
s'est inscrit dans une perspective
quinquennal et non pas décennale avec
des renforts que nous proposons nous
estimons qu'il est possible de doter
donc la justice deux de ces renforts
dans un délai de cinq ans c'est
extrêmement ambitieux à tous les étages
y compris est celui des procédures de
recrutement la commission d'avancement
l'école de la magistrature
mais il nous semble important que
l'effort indispensable qui doit être
fait pour la justice puisse être réalisé
dans un délai de cinq ans en ce qui
concerne les solutions pour avoir plus
de magistrats civilistes il faut alors
là qu'on s'inscrive dans une gestion
prévisionnelle des effectifs
que l'institution définit ce que sont
ses besoins à moyen terme et que ensuite
effectivement les carrières soit gérée
dans cette perspective nous ne pouvons
pas enfin là je vais un peu au delà du
rapport et je m'aventure je m'expose aux
objections de mes collègues mais nous ne
pouvons pas avoir une gestion qui est
uniquement statutaire de la magistrature
il faut tenir compte des compétences et
il me semble qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
que ce soit dans l'administration ou
dans la justice aspyr précisément à
s'inscrire dans des parcours de carrière
qu'ils soient définis à l'avancé qu'ils
soient un peu prévu faut qu'il y ait de
la mobilité il faut qui est de
l'adaptation bien sûr mais je pense que
ce dispositif là est à notre portée il
vaut d'ailleurs pour la justice civile
stricto sensu comme pour la justice
économique c'est un point dont nous
n'avons pas parlé dans nos exposé
liminaire mais non nous avons délibéré
entre nous et qu'on retrouve dans le
rapport il faut créer dès le début de la
carrière une filière de magistrats
qu'ils soient compétents en matière
économique
de telle sorte que les décisions de la
justice ne puisse pas être critiqués ou
disqualifier sur le thème mais ces
personnes là ne connaissent pas ce type
de sujet ce qui implique ce qui implique
d'avoir des affectations interne mais
aussi même externe à l'institution
judiciaire qui tiennent compte de la
volonté d'acquérir des compétences
sur la régulation de la population
carcérale il ya une question d'accords
jour je vous laisserai la parole pour la
régulation de la population carcérale
pas de numerus clausus
mais la définition par établissement
d'un seuil de criticité et lorsque ce
seuil de criticité est atteint on met en
place on devrait mettre en place de
manière préventive des mesures de
gestion de la population pénitentiaire
de telle sorte que l'on puisse avoir
notamment des libérations
conditionnelles
mais voilà il ne faut pas qu'on ait des
seuils qu'on constate mécaniquement il
faut qu'ils aient une gestion
prévisionnelle pour que des sorties
puisse être anticipé l'important étant
non pas de faire 20 le risque c'est la
sortie sèche en fin de peine sans aucune
perspective de reclassement et
d'accompagnement
c'est ça aujourd'hui le vrai danger de
la justice c'est pas que des personnes
puissent avoir une libération
conditionnelle
quinze jours ou 30 jours plus tôt enfin
sur les maisons de la justice et du
droit quel avenir c'est la grande
question ce sont effectivement les
parents pauvres et avec le renforcement
des moyens qui est proposé on doit
pouvoir
avoir des greffiers des greffiers en
chef en nombre suffisant avec les
qualifications nécessaires pour tenir
ces postes car aujourd'hui je le
reconnais avec accablement la situation
n'est pas du tout satisfaisant madame la
première présidente et monsieur le
procureur général d'une question sur le
tribunal départemental
et peut-être sur ''le l'accès au droit
il ya 20 ans l'accès au droit
dans les maisons de justice était
vraiment une politique nationale du
ministère de la justice comme il y a eu
d'autres priorités comme
les victimes les violences faites aux
femmes et que le budget est contraint l
aide juridictionnelle également l'accès
au droit est devenu un peu le parent
pauvre des politiques publiques du
ministère de la justice et je pense que
je peux le dire pour les membres du
comité l'accès au droit c'est un une
prévention de
en même temps de l'accès à la
citoyenneté c'est à dire que quand les
citoyens ont accès aux maisons de
justice ont accès à un certain nombre
d'informations consultations juridiques
gratuites
sapally ensuite un certain nombre de
difficultés dans dans la société en
matière civile la question est complexe
parce qu'il n'ya pas que l'institution
judiciaire qui est concerné par la
désaffection dans les fonctions civiles
il y a le ministère de l'éducation il y
à l'école nationale de la magistrature
il ya le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
est ce que proposait le rapport de
l'inspection générale de la justice
auquel malheureusement le parlement n'a
pas accès c'est qu'il faudrait mettre
autour d'une table et l'éducation
nationale et le ministère de la justice
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour profiler des postes donc la réponse
ne peut pas venir que de l'institution
judiciaire mais suppose une réponse
globale
que le procureur général
on y arrive a lancé le procureur général
il ya deux questions pour moi si j'ai
bien retenu le tribunal criminel
départemental et données de connexion
tribunal criminel départemental ont bien
sûr je reconnais les la valeur d'une
grande assise avec un jury populaire
mais je pense qu'il faut aussi raisonner
en termes d'efficacité et on ne peut pas
accepter
je faisais pas acceptable aussi bien au
regard de l'auteur que de la victime
d'une affaire criminelle nécessite trois
ans pourra traduire c'est devant une
juridiction alors que des gens attendent
qu'on statue sur des choses qui sont
importantes dont je pense que le
tribunal criminel départemental pour moi
il se justifie au moins pour deux
raisons la première c'est de renforcer
l'efficacité de réduire les délais de
jugement et la seconde c'est de lutter
contre ces phénomènes de
correctionnalisations notamment souvent
en matière d'infractions sexuelles qu'on
a si souvent dénoncée simplement ce que
je regrette est ce que ce que j'ai voulu
dire tout à l'heure c'est que il était
prévu je parle très librement je
respecte tout à fait les choix de dd a
semblé j'ai pas de
jugement à porter là dessus mais ce qui
est dommageable c'est que alors qu'ils
avaient une période d'expérimentation
qui était prévu avec une évaluation qui
seraient venus aux termes on aurait
peut-être pu voir effectivement de façon
plus précise les gammes propos procuré
par cette nouvelle procédure ne le sait
pas et aujourd'hui je sais qu'il ya des
départements dans lesquels effectivement
c'est un vrai gars de passer devant
tribunal criminel départemental bon
d'autres le gain en terme de délai est
beaucoup plus discutable voilà
simplement donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faudra nécessairement prendre
le temps d'une évaluation objective et
approfondie des gains des inconvénients
de cette nouvelle procédure que encore
une fois dont je vois tout à fait les
avantages les données de connexion
le problème ça fait ça fait cinq ans
qu'ils aient posé monsieur le sénateur
ça fait cinq ans que la cour de justice
déjà à travers l'arsb rigueur qui doit
remonter à 2017 2018 qui a été confirmée
à trois ou quatre reprises a posé le
problème l'interdiction de la
conservation généraliser les données de
connexion et réglementer l'accès en
réservant l'accès des données de
connexion soit une autorité indépendante
soit un magistrat en réalité indépendant
à l'égard de la direction de l'anc est
[Musique]